Hallo herzlich willkommen
zu u k w unsere kleine welt und wie in den letzten ausgaben schon versuche ich hier ein paar hintergründe aufzutun die vielleicht nützlich sein können rund um die coronas krise
und dazu spreche ich heute mit frieda hallo frieda.
Hallo tim.
Frieda du bist auch aus dem medizinischen bereich und auch aus dem zerrt umfeld aus dem wir hier in den letzten ausgaben schon mehrfach leute gehört haben.
Vielleicht kannst du ja mal kurz sagen was so dein medizinischer hintergrund ist.
Also ich bin prinzipiell fachärztin für anästhesie logie mit der zusatzbezeichnung notfallmedizin.
Ich habe ja und ich habe noch die zusatzbezeichnung akupunktur und habe aber auch während meiner facharztausbildung schon mich um zwei jahre lang in der liste sie.
Rumgetrieben und habe da einfach gelernt wie man mit schwerkranken patienten in einer herz-op anästhesie logisch
sie betreut vernünftig und habe aber auch danach schon noch viel zeit auf intensiv gearbeitet also intensivmedizinisch habe ich zwar die zusatzbezeichnung nicht aber trotz alledem viel intensiv erfahrung.
Genau darüber wollte ich heute vor allem mal ein bisschen reden um mal so ein verständnis dafür zu bekommen was das eigentlich bedeutet intensivmedizinisch zu arbeiten.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zur erläuterung für leute die da in den fachbegriffen nicht so drinstecken anästhesie bezieht sich ja im wesentlichen auf die betäubung von patienten.
Wie.
Jeder der eine narkose braucht der trifft auf einen anästhesisten also ein narkosearzt der ihnen entsprechend mit dem verfahren sei es
eine betreuung mit sedierung oder an einem regionalen biologischen verfahren also der betäubung von einem körperbereich da ist klassisch halt die.
Spinalanästhesie also die beine werden ab dem bauchnabel taub für knie eingriffe zum beispiel oder eben eine vollnarkose.
Man schläft komplett und kriegt gar nichts mit.
Final hinten in die wirbelsäule quasi.
Nicht in die wirbelsäule aber ja in den rücken und dann im spült es quasi den rücken das rückenmark und betäubt die nerven die da sind und dann sind die entsprechend ja betäubt das ist man man spürt dann noch den druck.
Und das da gearbeitet wird aber es tut halt nicht mehr wie.
Das heißt intensivmedizin ist eigentlich ohne anästhesie überhaupt nicht zu denken.
Das sind schon zwei fachbegriffe also zwei fachbereiche die anästhesie ist halt wirklich im op
also da wo patienten operiert werden für was weiß ich am bauch vom blinddarm über eine große bauch- p vorteile des darms herausgenommen werden müssen weil er zum beispiel ein tumor ist oder weil da was blutet
bis hin zu was weiß ich knochenbrüchen und so weiter und davon gibt's dann ein teil der patienten die einfach schwer krank sind
sei es durch einen autounfall oder irgendwas ist da passiert oder der eingriff ist so groß
wie zum beispiel eine große lungen-op oder ein großer bauch po oder auch eine herz op dass die leute nicht nachdem sie aufgewacht sind oder nachdem die betäubung abklingt dann total fit sind und wieder
teilweise sogar nach hause gehen können das wäre eine ambulante op sondern oder auf normalstation gehen könnt sondern noch weiter intensiver geguckt werden müssen
personell technisch apparativ einfach noch mehr betreuung brauchen und die gehen dann auf der intensivstation.
So der begriff intensivstation intensivmedizin fällt natürlich in den letzten tagen ziemlich
oft vielleicht ist es auch nochmal ganz wertvoll klarzumachen wo wo fängt intensivmedizin an und was unterscheidet diese bereiche jetzt von den normalen betreuungsbereich.
Also intensivmedizin gibt's natürlich in verschiedenen formen also
jemand kann auch in einem krankenwagen oder spezifisch einem intensivtransport wagen
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden oder auf einem flugzeug das geht's primär um die ausstattung was ist da vorhanden für den normalen gebrauch und das was jetzt halt wichtig ist ist es eine intensivstation
das ist im prinzip ein spezieller bereich eines krankenhauses wenn man den normalen stations bereich sich anguckt da hat man ja.
Weiß nicht zwanzig dreißig vierzig patienten betten da ist ein arzt für zuständig der tagsüber hoffentlich auch da ist und nachts dann halt von einem dienstag arzt,
der auch die notaufnahme und so betreut dann mit abgedeckt wird das heißt er ist nicht rund um die uhr auf station verfügt
und die schwestern also da gibt's dann den sogenannten pflegeschlüssel wie viele schwestern braucht man um das ganze zu betreuen und der ist natürlich auf der normalstation auch sehr viel geringer
auf die.
Die sachen die man vor ort hält also vorhält was für technisches gerät habe ich da anwesend das ist auf einer normalstation ganz anders und dann guckt man auf die intensivstation da sieht's dann anders aus da ist man
ärztlicherseits und auch im pflegerischen nicht nur auf sie auf station sondern da sind beide berufsgruppen in der regel im vierundzwanzig
stunden schichtbetrieb das heißt je nachdem was für eine schicht form die genommen haben zwölf-stundenschichten oder acht stunden schichten und dann wird gewechselt das heißt da ist ein arzt zu jedem zeitpunkt
vor ort und die pflege kräfte sind was den
pflegeschlüssel angeht deutlich besser aufgestellt das heißt da wenn man sagt auf einer normalstation im schnitt gibt's irgendwie zwei schwestern oder so oder vielleicht auch drei je nachdem wie gut die aufgestellt sind.
Oder wie groß auf die station ist wenn das natürlich eine sechzig fetten station das braucht man mehr personal als für eine zwanzig betten station.
Dann ist das halt auf intensivstation sehr viel besser aufgestellt so dass man da einen anderen pflegeschlüssel hat und dann betreut halt die intensiv schwester nur zwei drei patienten
oder je nachdem wenn es nicht so gut läuft halt auch mehr.
Und der intensivstation hat im prinzip jedes krankenhaus.
Nein es gibt kleine krankenhäuser mit beleg krankenhäusern die halt sozusagen nicht konstant besetzt sind
die werden nicht unbedingt eine intensivstation vorhalten die haben vielleicht ein bisschen erweiterten aufwacht raum das ist normalerweise das was,
wenn man aus dem op kommt dass man in der phase da nicht direkt zurück auf station geht wo dann vielleicht wo dann eben die zwei drei krankenschwestern gar nicht so die chance haben den patienten noch besser im auge zu haben sondern in der kritischen phase
nach dem aufwachen um den op auch leer zu kriegen um weitermachen zu können gehen die patienten in einen sogenannten aufwacht raum
so einfach ein monitor ist wo man sauerstoff geben kann wo man halt die einfach noch viel besser im auge hat,
und die haben dann vielleicht ein vierundzwanzig stunden betrieb vom raum und beobachten dann die patienten die.
In diesen krankenhäusern werden aber dann auch nicht so große operationen durchgeführt als dass die patienten intensivmedizinisch länger betreut werden müssen das sind dann eher so
wir verlängern das ganze ein bisschen gucken nochmal was weiß ich vierundzwanzig stunden nach der op das die stabil bleiben zum beispiel nach einer hüft-op ob's blutet oder nicht ob die schmerzen gut eingestellt sind oder nicht und dann gehen sie auf normalstation.
Auf warum ist so ein typischer arbeitsbereich auch für die anästhesisten.
Ja die anästhesisten sind da also ja es kommt auf die größe drauf an dann hat man vielleicht auch einen auffahrrampen arzt der aufwachen arzt wird aber gerne auch mal in was weiß ich in der mittagspause dann von dem aufwachen
zum pausen auslösen geschickt
und dann ist er halt wenn da was ist kann man den oberarzt anrufen und ansonsten ist der halt schon vor ort aber das kommt immer so ein bisschen auf die personaldecke darauf an
schwestern sind aber auch besser von der von dem betreuungsverhältnis vorhanden und natürlich auch das monitor plätze und sauerstoff plätze und so als auf normalstation da kommen aber primär nur patienten hin von denen man ausgeht
dass sie sich innerhalb von ein zwei drei stunden so bekrabbelt oder dass man sagt man muss jetzt noch zwei stunden gucken dass da zum beispiel nach einer schilddrüse nichts anschwillt
dass man die ruhigen gewissens auf die normalstation verlegen kann dann kann man dem aufwachen lassen wenn vorher schon klar ist dieser patient.
Wird eine intensivtherapie brauchen dann geht er gehen sie nicht über aufwacht raum sondern direkt auf intensiv verlegt.
Und wenn sich aber jetzt was herausstellt dass im raum patient dann doch nicht so gut.
Entwickelt das soll was weiß ich doch nicht so kreislauf stabil ist und noch ein bisschen mehr aufmerksamkeit braucht dann kann man da gucken was man
schon mal so ein bisschen therapieren und gucken ob der sich fängt und ob dann alles gut ist und der auf normalstation gehen kann oder aber man sagt okay hier ist jetzt
nicht wahrscheinlich dass wir das in den nächsten zwei drei stunden lösen das wird bis morgen noch ein bisschen brauchen und dann wird er auf einer intensivstation oder eine intermediate station verlegt.
Jetzt.
Ist es also was jetzt klar wird ist intensivstation ist vor allem erstmal personell anders aufgestellt hat halt andere aufgaben aber damit wird ja dann auch eine gewisse mindestanforderung an technischer und medizinische ausstattung verbunden sein,
wie,
würdest du sagen ist so eigentlich ein typischer intensiv medizinischer bereich an einem platz ausgestattet was was für geräte sind da unerlässlich und was hängt auch davon ab worauf man sich vielleicht spezialisiert hat.
Also natürlich ist es so dass in einer herzchirurgischen intensivstation andere größeren geräte im zweifelsfall mehr vorhanden sind als auf einer allgemeinen intensivstation die gar keine herzchirurgie hat ihr braucht das nicht
es gibt immer so eine basisausstattung die hat,
jede intensivstation dafür gibt's auch entsprechende checklisten und voraussetzungen damit sie sich intensivstation nennen dürfen da hat jeder
platz der da ist hat die möglichkeit in aufgerüstet zu werden also erstmal ist es so er hat immer ein monitor stehen das heißt der patient wird auf einer intensivstation
kontinuierlich überwacht dafür gibt es verschiedene methoden manche davon sind halt nur alle zehn minuten oder so einen wert
für die blutdruckmessung man kann aber auch eine form der blutdruckmessung machen wo man's einfach online die ganze zeit sieht.
Und dauerhaft sieht dass ich nicht die manschette mehr aufpumpt das hängt vom patienten ab was braucht er dann haben sie alle sauerstoffanhebung wir haben alle druckluft anschluss sie haben alle so ein.
Ja sind so ein bügel set und die möglichkeit da perfusoren aufzubauen perfusoren sind im prinzip spritzen pumpen
wo man dann einfach kontinuierlich medikamente abgeben kann sei es zum unterstützen des blutdrucks weil der blutdruck zu niedrig ist dass sie kontinuierlich ein.
Bisschen medikament bekommen da wären dann jetzt lauf raten
ohne die speziellen dosierung zu meinen dass man dann sagt ok bei dieser stützen pumpe von diesem medikament kriegt der patient drei milliliter die stunde
oder zehn milliliter die stunde das ist im prinzip das was man einstellen kann man kann es natürlich auch das sind inzwischen deutlich technischer
ausgerüstete kleine computer mit denen man natürlich auch sagt da ist das medikament drin das hat die dosierung und jetzt mach mal was weiß ich kontinuierlich ein milligramm pro kilogramm körpergewicht pro stunde.
Aber das ist im prinzip nur eine form von früher hätte man es mit den alten geräten hätte man es ausgerechnet.
Wieviel braucht der patient auf seinen kilogramm körpergewicht und stellt danach die milliliter die stunde ein die neuen die kann dann halt entsprechend das.
Ein bisschen einfacher machen dass man nicht mehr rechnen muss.
Und das ist sozusagen die grundausstattung also man hat so drei vier geräte.
Das ist das ist sozusagen der einzelnen patienten am patienten platz gibt's dann noch eine absaugung des.
Ähm dann entsprechend das intensiv bett was von den technischen möglichkeiten her anders ist als das
ich sage mal schnöde patienten wird auf normalstation das kann zwar auch füße runter füße hoch kopf runter schlag liegen und so aber das intensiv bett weil die patienten einfach anders gefährdet sind weil die nicht sich unbedingt so viel bewegen können wie jemand der eine nase operiert gekriegt hat und laufen kann
dass die halt andere matratzen haben dass die keine druckstellen entwickeln dass die elektrische.
Elektrisch gelagert werden können dass die schwestern die sehr viel lagern müssen auf intensiv weil sich die patienten in der regel nicht selber bewegen können da entsprechend entlastet sind vom rücken dass man den
bett hoch runter und so dass alles elektrisch machen kann dann gibt es in jedem raum auch immer noch ein
ein wagen wo eigentlich alles an verbrauchs materialien ist was man ganz oft braucht also was weiß ich spritzen.
Oder die die spitzen obendrauf also die kanülen mit denen man irgendwas aufziehen kann ein gewisses im zweifelsfall eine gewisse anzahl von medikamenten die man immer braucht so was weiß ich auch nur so ganz.
Banale sachen wie sauberes wasser zum nachspülen von irgendwelchen leitungen oder.
Zugänge patienten kriegen zugänge in die wehen die gehen auch manchmal kaputt oder der patient ist nicht so ganz bei sich und die ziehen die sich raus
und da muss man den neu machen und dass man nicht jedes mal einmal quer durch die station laufen kann muss um das zu haben sind die materialien in der regel in dem in dem zimmer vorhanden.
Im normalen intensivzimmer das kommt darauf an wie neu die sind die neueren intensivzimmer haben in der regel oft nur noch ein zimmer betten.
Das ist aber bei den meisten die ich kenne eher bei zweibettzimmern manchmal gibt es auch noch welche mit drei betten aber das ist.
Was größeres ist da eigentlich nicht machbar weil die patienten das ja auch dass da gibt's dann halt noch so ein flatter vorhang zwischen den patienten dass die was weiß ich die die gestürzt
roller-fahrerin die eigentlich nicht viel hat aber jetzt toll einmal einen auf dem kopf gekriegt hat bei diesem sturz und überwacht werden muss dass sie nicht irgendwie doch noch eine schlimmere symptomatik entwickelt als kopfweh dass man die beobachten kann
während daneben halt ein schwer kranker patient liegt der beatmet ist dass die halt nicht die ganze zeit den ganzen zugucken muss und soll
auch um privatsphäre für den anderen patienten zu gewähren.
Und dann gibt's natürlich auch immer noch ganz viele geräte auf einer intensiv die halt nicht für jeden platz vorhanden sind wie zum beispiel beatmungsgeräte ich kenne.
Eigentlich keine intensiv zumindest vor korona die für jeden platz den sie hat beatmungspflege platz vorfällt.
Weil die beatmungsgeräte sind halt teuer und entsprechend hat man so man weiß wie viel man ungefähr hat und das ist in der regel so wenn man jetzt
ohne kurve denkt dass man sagt okay so und so viel prozent der patienten sind in der regel intubiert dann haben wir immer aber auch welche die halt nicht intubiert sind
dann gibt's noch maschinen die eine sogenannte nicht invasive beatmung können das heißt da kriegt man wie so eine maske für schnarcher ein bisschen ähnlich vom prinzip aber die können noch ein bisschen mehr auf die nase so eine
so eine gesichtsmaske aufgesetzt und dann wird die atmung unterstützt ohne dass man so einen schlauch im hals hat.
Also intubiert heißt schlauch rein.
Genau intubiert heißt da ist ein schlauch der bis in die luftröhre reicht und dann wird die lunge von außen komplett.
Wird die atmung funktion.
Quasi in der regel komplett übernommen es gibt eine situation wenn man versucht den patienten wieder vom schlauch abzugewöhnen dass man auch am schlauch atmen kann mit unterstützung.
Um das zu trainieren wenn die leute länger sind das zwerchfell ist auch ein muskel das ist unser haupt muskel das.
Ist ein mutmuskel der genauso trainiert werden muss und wenn man zwei wochen nicht beatmet selber geatmet hat dann musste er auch erstmal auftrainiert werden
und dann übt man und dann macht man je länger die leute probiert waren wer wer eine narkose hat ist überhaupt kein problem also ein zwei stunden wenn man ein zwei tage hat dann ist das in der regel auch kein problem aber wenn ein patient ist der zum beispiel eine hirnblutung hatte und der jetzt schon zwei drei wochen
beatmet war ohne dass er selber das gemacht hat den muss man natürlich dann erstmal wieder trainieren
jeder der schon mal ein gips arm hatte und weiß wie der arm aussieht wenn man nach sechs wochen das ding abkriegt das muss man auch erstmal wieder trainieren.
Alles was man nicht benutzt das vergisst der körper auch schnell ne.
Ja das ist das ist mit hirn fähigkeiten also denkfähigkeit genauso wie mit muskel tätigkeit used look.
Ja
dann wird ja schon einmal relativ klar der aufwand ist doch vergleichsweise hoch so eine ausstattung wenn man sagt wir bieten jetzt ein medizin schon wir bieten ein intensiv bett dann ist es halt nicht ein bett.
Es ist halt erst mal ein tolles bett was viel kann und teuer ist und natürlich dann eben je nachdem wie man jetzt durchzieht mit vier fünf geräten die im prinzip pro platz vorhanden sein müssen.
Natürlich.
Mehr ja.
Oder mehr halt aber eben auch mit der entsprechenden infrastruktur dahinter ausfallsichere stromversorgung etcetera wasserversorgung und was da eben alles noch so mit dranhängt.
Ganz viel also da gibt es ganz viele regularien die ich jetzt auch im einzelnen gar nicht alle kenne aber auch ist auch die beatmungsgeräte sind nicht das einzige gerät was man nicht für alle
patienten vorhält es gibt natürlich auch noch abhängig von der größe der intensiv die möglichkeit nieren ersatzverkehr fahren zu machen also wenn die niere die funktion einstellt dass man eine temporäre dialyse macht auch wenn's nicht ganz dialyse vom prinzip ist aber so kann man sich vorstellen dass die blutwäsche für die niere übernommen wird
davon gibt es einen geräte dann gibt's geräte die den kreislauf unterstützen gerade in herz intensivst kann man noch mit verschiedenen pumpen das herz unterstützen man kann sogar
also das maximale variante von intensivtherapie ist im prinzip ein patient der eine nieren-ersatztherapie hat
eine lunge und eine herz also kreislauf und lunge maschine quasi mit dabei hat
also das was im herz op funktioniert kann man inzwischen auch auf intensivstation in speziellen zentrum machen
und dass man einfach sowohl die dass die die sauerstoff und versorgung vom blut und das der abtransport von kohlendioxid.
Genauso wie die pumpe leistung des herzens also die verteilung dieses sauerstoff im blut durch eine maschine unterstützt oder übernimmt für eine gewisse zeit.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich die spezielle situation dass ich das deutsche gesundheitssystem auf die potentielle belastung mit vielen corvin neunzehn patienten einstellen muss.
Und wir sind ja zum aktuellen zeitpunkt wir sollten vielleicht mal das datum nennen das könnte ganz hilfreich sein in der zukunft einunddreißigster märz
wir sind jetzt in der situation dass wir einige länder erleben die eine ganze menge probleme haben die extrem überlastet sind vor allem ist natürlich da italien mittlerweile auch spanien zu nennen den usa,
zeichnet sich das teilweise auch schon ab beziehungsweise ist in new york auch schon relativ krass in deutschland haben wir noch ja.
Ein bisschen die ruhe vor dem sturm wie nimmst du das wahr wie das deutsche system sich darauf eingestellt hat also wenn ich es jetzt erstmal richtig mitnehme ist es ja so,
all das was wir jetzt aufgezählt haben was man im prinzip zu einem intensiv platz zählen kann nicht alles wird zwangsläufig jetzt in dem maße benötigt.
Wenn man jetzt die perspektive hat dass viele patienten behandelt werden müssen.
Na ja es ist grundsätzlich sind.
Patienten nach allem was ich bisher gelesen habe was den berichten aus erfahrungsberichten aus anderen ländern aus dem publikationen ist es so dass die die corvette patienten einfach schon.
Etwas spezieller sind dass zum einen die leute wenn die auf station sind oder auch schon auf intensiv überwacht werden aber noch nicht beatmet werden müssen mit einem gartenschlauch.
Dass die einfach subjektiv wach sind.
Das gar nicht so merken wie schlecht eigentlich die versorgung schon ist und.
Der körper kann ganz viel kompensieren und dass die leute dann quasi da sitzen und gar nicht so merken dass die luft nötig sind oder dass die dass das.
Gerade in die falsche richtung geht und dass sie dann erklärt kriegen müssen wir müssen sie jetzt intubieren und die da einfach wach bei sind.
Noch vorhin gegen andere patienten die mit so einer schweren sauerstoff versorgt mit sauerstoff in der krankenhaus sind oftmals.
Dann so krank sind dass die schon nicht mehr ganz so bei bewusstsein sind dass die halt wir nennen das dann eingetrübt sind oder dass die schläfrig sind und das nicht mehr so mitkriegen und wenn sie sich erschöpfen aber das.
Spezielle bei den patienten ist wohl tatsächlich dass sie relativ fit noch sind was das was die bilanz also das wachsein angeht und
von den werten das subjektiv gar nicht so mitnehmen wenn man dann aber mal eine bgb das ist ein blutgase analyse also etwas wo man.
Ein zwei milliliter blut abnimmt und dann vor auf einer intensivstation ist das auch immer vorhanden reinsteckt und dann kommt innerhalb von zwei minuten oder weniger halt eine ganz lange liste mit mit untersuchungen wo unter anderem auch die sauerstoff
sättigung im blut und der potential druck vom sauerstoff und co zwei vorhanden sind und die sind dann teilweise schon
sehr viel schlechter als der klinische zustand also wie der patient sich präsentiert wenn man neben dem bett steht und keine werte hat es eigentlich vermuten lassen
und das ist das eine spezielle das andere spezielle ist dass diese patienten primär gar kein also
die lunge macht zwei hat zwei aufgabe zwei große aufgaben es gibt noch ein paar mehr aber in bezug auf beatmung die ist einmal dazu da dass sauerstoff.
In den körper rein kommt und dass der körper dann als abfallprodukt von der art von von den stoffwechselprodukten das co zwei auch wieder raus
los wird also dass es rauskommt und oft haben man unterscheidet das tatsächlich auch ob einen patient nur ein sauerstoff problem hat,
oder nur ein co zwei probleme hat oder beides hat und oft sind solche patienten mit schweren lungenerkrankungen die nicht kurve haben wir haben in der regel.
Beides also ein problem auf beiden seiten co zwei und sauerstoff und die patienten haben wohl isoliert ein sauerstoff problem das heißt die co zwei werden sie gut los
was aber auch so eine eintragung tatsächlich erklärt
also wenn das so hoch ist dann ist man nicht mehr so ganz wach und haben halt nur ein problem quasi mit dem mit dem sauerstoff.
Das ist ein so eine spezielle besonderheit.
Das hat das hat was konkret damit zu tun dass halt der virus besonders eben die zelle in der lunge aktiv angeht und im schlimmsten fall auch noch das immunsystem überdreht und
mit dem virus sozusagen weiterhin den körper bekämpft weil eine überreaktion vorliegt.
Ja aber leider ist es wie fast immer in der medizin nicht ganz so einfach also auch bei einem also das was die patienten entwickeln unter kobalt wenn sie einen schweren verlauf haben ist ein sogenanntes das werden
ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon mal irgendwo gelesen haben das ist ein acuh restauratorin distress syndrom also ein akutes atemnot syndrom oder auch lungenverschleimung einfach.
Und das kann bei verschiedenen erkrankungen auftreten das kann auftreten wenn
eine verletzung oder einen sturz aus großer höhe ist und da einfach eine lungenschäden durch die kinetische.
Einwirkung von energie entstanden ist es kann auch im rahmen von chronischen lungenpest dessen wenn da noch ein akuter infekt,
dazu kommt stattfinden das kann auch einfach nur durch in anführungsstrichen nur durch ein bakterium oder was weiß ich ein influencer viren also ein grippevirus entstehen.
Aber dann ist trotzdem also das ist dann auch eine lungenschäden übung der lungenbläschen und da verändert sich die lunge strukturell
das ist ähnlich wie das was das kostet macht aber der mechanismus von von dem corona virus ist einfach so dass es ein bisschen.
Anders die lunge wahrscheinlich schädigt genau weiß ich es nicht wissen wir glaube ich alle nicht warum die patienten da nur dann sauerstoff problem haben was aber passiert ist dass die lungenbläschen bei diesem
patienten die wirklich ein ko wird
also das ist ja dieses korona v i d e also die erkrankung haben und nicht nur den virus selber
dass die tatsächlich ein problem haben dass sich die lungenbläschen nicht mehr entfalten
das heißt dass bestimmte lungenarzt abschnitte nicht belüftet werden das nennt sich dann auf schlau atelier hase also dass da bestimmte bereiche einfach ja wie so ein zusammengefallene luftballon sind und nicht mehr dran
spielt nicht mehr mit na so und dass das halt ein großes problem ist und dann hast hat man zum einen das problem dass man das kann man sich
wenn man ein bisschen einfach nur sich überlegt wie
lunge und blut sich verhalten wenn man steht ist natürlich mehr luft oben in der lunge und in den abschnitten weiter unten der schwerkraft folgend ist dann mehr blut
als luft wenn die patienten dann liegen dann ist das natürlich so dass hinten mehr mehr blut ist und oben mehr luft also vorne auf dem brustkorb
im vorderen bereich.
Und unten finden sind dann auch mehr von diesen atelier hasen vorhanden außerdem ist es so dass die lunge im rahmen der entzündung von kovac.
Feuchtigkeit einlagert das heißt dass da deutlich mehr flüssigkeit aus dem körper durch diese entzündungsreaktion in der lunge vorhanden ist das ist dann so ein bisschen im mediziner umgang sprechen ist die haben eine feuchte lunge,
und das ist etwas was einfach auch diesen sauerstofftransport behindern kann was den patienten.
Unglaublich gut tut intensiv in der intensiven medizinischen therapie was aber logistisch eine riesen herausforderung ist ist dass die lange auf dem bauch liegen.
Also dass die quasi gewendet werden dass die abschnitte die mehr blut haben.
Damit auch mehr flüssigkeit haben und da wo mehr luft ist in den oberen abschnitten dass ich das umkehrt,
ich weiß nicht achtzehn stunden ist glaube ich die empfehlung täglich auch auf den bauch liegen und das einfach dann entsprechend die luft in die oberen abschnitte gehen kann und da auch diese zusammengefallene lungenbläschen sich wiedereröffnen können.
Und dann das einfach die lunge wieder komplett an der an dem sauerstoff austausch teilnimmt das hilft diesen patienten sehr.
Die haben aber im gegensatz zu anderen patienten mit lungenerkrankungen oder auch intensiv medizinischen erkrankungen.
An vielen stellen wohl weniger baustellen also ganz viele patienten die schwer krank sind haben zusätzlich noch dass der blutdruck,
nicht im normalen bereich ist sondern dass sie zu wenig blutdruck aufbauen dass sie dann probleme haben wenn der blutdruck nicht gut genug ist dass dann die nieren.
Die nieren sind im prinzip filter und wenn da kein druck auf dem filter ist dann.
Stellen die auch ihre arbeit ein das heißt die patienten hören auf pipi zu machen.
Und so dass diese probleme oftmals gar nicht so vorherrscht natürlich kommen die an irgendeinem punkt im zweifelsfall noch dazu wenn man pech hat das aber so die die.
Patienten mit einem schweren verlauf das gar nicht so im vordergrund steht am anfang.
Was immer passieren kann gerade wenn man länger beatmet ist leider ist dass man eine lungenentzündung noch obendrauf hat nicht nur dass man also leuse und früher hat dass man nicht nur diese kurve lungenentzündung hat.
Sondern auch noch dadurch dass dein beatmung schlauch drin steckt und dann damit eine straße vom rachenbereich bis in die lunge gebahnt ist
das ist immer so wenn man länger beatmet ist dass das risiko deutlich steigt das dann bakterien einfach sich auch noch in der lunge festsetzen und dann da noch eine bakterielle entzündung drüber
draufsetzen das seit zwei probleme in der lunge vorhanden sind.
Das sind dann diese socken die dann zum einsatz kommen.
Nicht nur klamotten das können ganz viele andere bakterien aufmachen aber ja mal gucken sind da auch für typisch.
Genau und ich erinnere mich jetzt nur gerade dass bei angela merkel als jetzt der verdacht war dass ihr das vielleicht sich auch hätte einfangen können dann auch schon mal vorher nochmal geimpft wurde gegen die erkrankung ne.
Mal gucken haben halt den vorteil im gegensatz die haben einfach den vorteil im vergleich zu vielen anderen keimen die wir alle in unserer mundhöhle haben gegen die können wir impfen.
Grundsätzlich besteht immer eine empfehlung gegen plan bekommen für leute mit eingeschränkten immunsystem für ältere patienten über fünfundsechzig und für kleine kinder die kriegen auch eine pflaume gucken impfung.
Und die anderen sind im prinzip wenn sie gesund sind gefeilt wenn man dann aber natürlich.
Vom immunsystem her ein problem hat oder irgendwie schwere grunderkrankung hat dann gilt auch da die sollte man impfen weil dann die flamme gucken halt auch relevant werden können aber es gibt ganz viele andere keime die auch mit mit lustigen namen die die auch
lungenentzündung oder hervorrufen können.
Die bedrohung ist vielfältig ich habe gehört dass dieser immer ich habe auch gehört dass dieser impfstoff ein bisschen knapp geworden ist.
Ja der ist moment quasi nicht mehr verfügbar auch für risikogruppen nicht also
die die über fünfundsechzig sind oder wenn man sagt okay es macht jetzt für unsere mitarbeiter total viel sinn weil die halt ein hohe gefahr dass sie auch sich mit
mit corona virus anstecken während der arbeit dass wir die jetzt zum beispiel alle impfen würden dass sie zumindest dann vor diesem träume kochen gefeiert sind es ist im moment nicht mehr möglich.
Reden wir doch mal kurz über den schutz der mitarbeiter in der intensivmedizin haben wir jetzt noch nicht erwähnt aber auch das gehört ja zur ausstattung mit dazu und befindet sich ja auch gerade im zentrum der debatte durch den
offensichtlich ein mangel der hier vorliegt was ist denn sozusagen geboten auf
in welchem maße man sich eigentlich oder in welchem maße man das personal schützen sollte und sich das personal selbst schützt.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so dass man auf intensiv deutlich häufiger oder oder,
noch wichtiger als bei anderen patienten denen halt es soweit nicht so schlimm geht.
Kein begegnet die man nicht haben möchte insbesondere die die so die leute kennen ist emmerich aber es gibt noch andere resistente erreger oder irgendwelche durchfallserkrankung,
oder wie ein roter beruf jan und so weiter die man nicht haben möchte.
Also sind multiresistente oder was.
Das sind in dem fall also ist ist abkürzung gewusel für medizinrecht systemantisch staphylokokken kokos aura das ist ein,
das meinte ich mit sie haben alle lustige namen das ist ein keim der mit vornamen staphylococcus
und aureus mit internationalen staffel ist eigentlich der nachname also der der der stamm der korken ist staphylococcus aureus ist die farbe die es macht nämlich golden wenn man ihn anzüchtete und die sind gegen ein spezielles medikament resistent das ist die definition eines medizin.
Also eines medizinieren resistenter staphylococcus aus es gibt aber noch ganz viele andere die resistent werden die heißen in wenn man sie über einen kamm scheren möchte einfach multiresistenter erreger.
Da gibt es aber auch ganz viele und da ist aber das problem so wenn man da eine schleuse macht das ist wichtig dass man das macht das ist wichtig dass man vernünftig auf hände desinfektion achtet gerade auf intensiv walde einfach andere schwer kranke patienten sind.
Komme aber das sind keime die jetzt den personal an sich wenig anhaben.
Diese keime haben für gesunde menschen wenig konsequent außer dass sie auf ihn wohnen und viel schlimmer dass man sie zu leuten trägt.
Die davon krank werden weil sie so schon schwer krank sind das beispiel wäre es gibt einen patienten der hat wenn man
da jetzt nicht darauf achten würde man macht da intensiv pflege am bett irgendwas dann geht mal rüber zum beatmen patienten fast an die absaugung und wenn man pech hat dann
kann er es halt schaffen in den
absauge wenn man da nicht sauber gearbeitet hat und dann hat der patient der ein anderes problem hat auf einmal in der lunge der ist aber schon schwer krank da kann sich der körper nicht gegen wehren und dann hat er am ende vielleicht sogar eine eine lungenentzündung vom rsa.
Oder der sitzt dann den wunden und geht da nicht weg
also das ist das ist sozusagen das das normale problem das sieht bei norovirus und so schon anders aus also durchfall erreger dass da auch das personal krank werden kann
aber norovirus ist halt selbst limitierend im prinzip in ein paar tagen wo es einem wirklich nicht gut geht und so das aber ein gesunder mitarbeiter vom vom pflege oder von vom vom gesundheitswesen da zwar dann auch.
Krank wird aber der wird da ist dann halt ein paar tage ausgefallen aber der kommt dann auch wieder und dem geht's dann gut das problem jetzt ist das ist halt ein erreger.
Und dieser corona virus ist für uns alle neu.
So wie die kinder auf die welt kommen die am anfang noch keine keime kennen und sich erst mal damit auseinandersetzen muss und dann vielleicht auch,
ein bisschen mehr husten oder ein bisschen mehr keime haben krankheiten haben ist das so dass wir im laufe unseres lebens dann einfach vom immunsystem
viele viele viele erreger die uns krank machen kennengelernt haben und dagegen haben wir unser immunsystem die können die abwehren und dann haben wir danach kein problem mehr.
Bei dem bei dem corona virus jetzt ist es aber so den kennen wir alle nicht das heißt unser immunsystem steht dem gegenüber wie.
Ein kleines kind also kennst du noch nicht hat noch keine waffen und die gefahr jetzt ist das dass dieser corona virus einfach hochinfektiös ist.
Auch längerfristig dann krank macht und auch schwere verläufe haben kann weil sonst gesunden patienten auch wenn natürlich dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das eine schweren verlauf nimmt je älter die patienten sind hier kränker die patienten
sind desto wahrscheinlicher ist das aber es können auch junge gesunde patienten krank werden und zwar schwer und,
diese können diese jungen gesunden patienten oder auch vielleicht mittelalter patienten mit einem risikofaktor können im gesundheitswesen arbeiten was,
ja normal ist das ja genauso ein durchschnitt der bevölkerung nur dass sie wenn sie jetzt nicht anstecken in einer situation wo die krankenhäuser volllaufen.
Und das vorlaufen ist insofern dass es zwar am anfang vielleicht betten gibt aber das problem ist jeder patient der beatmet werden muss mit cohen wird.
Der wird wenn es gut läuft zwei wochen beatmet werden wenn es schlecht läuft drei wochen.
Nein andersrum die die schlechten verlauf nehmen und vielleicht auch daran versterben die versterben in der regel nach zwei wochen.
Die die einen guten verlauf nehmen wir brauchen voll im schnitt ungefähr drei wochen am beatmungsgeräte und da kommen aber ja jeden tag neue nach.
Und das ist das problem was wir halt haben ist dass diese beatmungsgeräte dann einfach voll sind und besetzt sind oder wo ist das wir haben werden mit großer wa.
Lass uns da gleich nochmal drüber reden nochmal bezüglich der schutzmaßnahmen also es wird ja jetzt viel drüber diskutiert was was halt alles fehlt was
was fehlt oder was was es überhaupt noch sonst erforderlich also die bedrohung ist denke ich jetzt klar geworden aber was braucht man denn normalerweise.
Na ja normalerweise wenn jetzt mit den anderen keimen aus gestern reicht das das sagt dann immer die hygiene was reicht manche brauchen einen mundschutz manche brauchen einen kittel und einen mundschutz manche keime brauchen einen kittel einen mundschutz an der haube beim kurve ist es so dass.
Wenn man im zoo ist braucht man nicht nur einen mundschutz sondern dann braucht man wenn man hohe erosol.
Konzentration hat wie das zum beispiel bei einer logen spiegelung ist wenn das der patient braucht oder auch bei einer intubation oder auch bei einer extraportion also warten schlauch rein beatmung schlauch raus.
Da entstehen hohe konzentration und wenn man die einatmet dann wird man krank.
Also soll heißt einfach kleinste tröpfchen sozusagen mehr sowie luftfeucht
schon fast und wo dann der virus unter umständen mit drin ist obwohl auch wenn es ja jetzt eigentlich in der öffentlichen kommunikation immer gesagt wird ist es jetzt wenn er aus genießt wird so dann ist er ja eher in den schweren tröpfchen zu finden als in diesem rossol
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja der wird auch sicherlich in den erosol sein wenn man jetzt in der öffentlichkeit sich begegnet draußen vielleicht noch ein bisschen wind ist da ist einfach und man dann einmal niest und man dann auch noch im besten fall abstand hat da passiert nicht allzu viel,
deswegen ist es nicht so relevant wie das in so einer kleinen intensiv box ist wo man dann mit kopf des patienten steht
um den zu intubieren oder auf zwanzig zentimeter ran muss dass man die bronchoskopie machen kann.
Dann ist da natürlich eine viel höhere konzentration weil's direkt aus der lunge kommt und weil's
auch weniger luft volumen ist und weil man da länger drin steht und die luft umwälzung nicht so gut ist wie draußen
also das verteilungskurve ist kleiner und wenn man dann halt nur den mund nasen- schutz hat den man aus dem op kennt
dann ist das eigentlich nicht ausreichend der kanzler und gewissen prozentsatz abhalten aber eigentlich ist da vorgesehen die sogenannte fdp drei maske mindestens.
Zwei.
Das steht das steht für face protection also spezielle atemschutzmasken die halt jetzt noch mal eine richtige versiegelung haben.
Die sind nicht versiegelt die haben einfach eine kleinere poren größe zum einen sitzen die sehr dicht an wenn man die mal getragen hat das ist echt.
Eng und unangenehm damit einfach man zwar nicht vorne was das ist quasi so ich halte mir was vor vor das
gesicht und armen aber zur seite raus also wenn die nicht dicht ansetzen dann zieht man natürlich nimmt der luft den geweckt des geringsten widerstandes und kommt durch die seiten.
Zum einen und zum anderen ist die poren größe bei drei also die fpö drei masken haben wir nicht richtig im kopf hab ne poren größe von sechshundert nanometern das heißt teilchen die größer sind kommen da nicht durch,
das ist eigentlich das was du brauchst dann brauchst du um dich einfach vor schmieren also dass du sekrete in denen der virus drin ist sei es speichel oder irgendwas anderes.
An der hand hast dann brauchst du handschuhe am besten doppelt
dann brauchst du ein visier dass wenn irgendwie mal so ein tröpfchen fliegt das ist nicht groß das muss man nicht unbedingt merken aber auch das passiert
dass es dann nicht direkt ins gesicht geht das heißt man möchte ein visier oder eine abschließende schutzbrille haben also nicht nur die normale brille wo es unten oben rechts und links immer noch ins auge spritzen kann
oder eben so ein visier zum drüberziehen dann braucht man noch am besten haube.
Damit wenn man dann an die haare kommt weil die haare kann man sich nicht sofort waschen wenn's dann da ist dass man sich hinterher da dran fasst es von da dann mitnimmt und sich da dann in die augen oder an den mund oder so wenn man sich unbewusst dann doch dran fasst.
Ja
Abbekommt deswegen auch genauso dann eben entsprechend schutz kittel das heißt im optimalfall sieht die schutzausrüstung die vorgesehen ist für den bereich wo man.
Hohen erosol kontakt hat nämlich intubation bronchoskopie also die lungen spiegelung und den gartenschlauch legen so dass man eine f drei maske tragen sollte ein visier oder eine schutzbrille tragen sollte.
Letztlich auch ein kopf habe so ein kopfschutz tragen sollte dass dass man es nicht in die haare kriegt dann.
Kittel und.
Handschuhe am besten doppelt dass man's aussieht problem ist nämlich wenn man da kleinste mengen abkriegt und da ist das anziehen weniger schwierig als das ausziehen des materials wenn's verschmutzt ist.
Dass man da gibt's ganz also von der who auch empfehlungen wie man aus solchen infektionen zu lösen klamotten rauskommt ohne sich selber anzustecken und das ist das muss man üben.
Aber damit man üben kann muss man's halt auch haben in ausreichender menge und das ist was was.
Meiner wahrnehmung nach der durchschnittliche arzt und die durchschnittliche krankenschwester so richtig gut geübt selten bis nie gemacht haben.
Also wie komme ich wirklich aus so einem.
Hochinfektiöse material aus ja ich kann mir einen kittel ausziehen und ich kriege das auch hin von a und so aber es.
Es ist noch mal eine andere hausnummer wenn es so infektiös ist und ich wirklich wirklich ist selber nicht abkriegen darf.
Das heißt nicht dass man es beim anderen machen nicht machen sollte heißt aber auch nicht dass es so richtig gut geübt und.
Eingespielt ist dass man das macht man wird empfiehlt sogar beim ausziehen weil es einfach auch so ein langer prozess ist man man desinfiziert sich die hände man zieht den handschuh aus dann desinfiziert man sich wieder die hände falls man was abgekriegt hat dann zieht man.
Entsprechend.
Die kleidung aus also diesen schutzanzug dann desinfiziert man sich die hände dann aber man hat man desinfiziert sich eigentlich nicht die hände sondern die die handschuhe dass das zweite paar handschuhe was man unter den handschuhen anhatte dann,
macht man weiter und zieht sich das visier aus dann desinfiziert man sich die hände und zieht
sieht die handschuhe aus man stopft das ganze nicht in den eimer sondern der muss nur locker reingelegt werden und dann oft getauscht werden und ausreichend groß sein damit man beim stopfen nicht wieder erosol aufwirbelt oder wie ein rostpartikel aufwirbelt dann geht man raus desinfiziert sich wieder die hände und dann setzt man die mahlzeit ab und desinfiziert sich wieder die hände.
Also es dauert und das eigentlich ist da empfohlen dass man zwei augen.
Macht das halt wirklich einer da steht und dich selber also dich beobachtet und aufpassen dass du auch wirklich jeden schritt richtig machst und hände desinfizieren ist ja auch noch mal so dass man's üben muss dass man wirklich alles erreicht hat also zwischen den fingern den daumen die nägel
die innenseiten die außenseiten und die handgelenke also das ist auch zwanzig sekunden und das dauert und deswegen ist es das was ich jetzt so aus italien.
Mitgekriegt habe ist dass die versuchen wirklich dieses zwei augen prinzip zu machen und dass die leute aber halt morgens einen kleinen schluck trinken dann vier fünf sechs stunden in die schicht in diesen anzug reingehen.
In der zeit nicht auf klo können in dieser zeit nichts essen um dann irgendwann wieder rauszugehen.
Weil's einfach zeitaufwendig ist mit dem an-und ausziehen und weil es natürlich auch ressourcen braucht.
Also wenn kittel und so knapp sind versuchst du natürlich möglichst wenig davon wegzuschmeißen weil du dich immer wieder an und aussiehst.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen also eigentlich im idealfall ist das alles einweg material.
Das ist alles ein wenig material im idealfall was aber von überall aus so was ich von überall aus italien irgendwie mitkriege und auch aus spanien ist
na ja wir haben jetzt also
also in amiland ist es so dass sie sich die bandanas die man so zum diese multifunktions-öl die man sich auf dem kopf ziehen kann und dann um hals und so dass sie das teilweise als mundschutz nehmen weil es einfach nichts anderes mehr gibt.
Das krankenhäuser jetzt.
Ich weiß es von einem die haben jetzt tatsächlich relativ früh reagiert die haben jetzt schon gemähte mundschützer mit der klaren anweisung
alle zwei stunden spätestens wechseln für das gesamte personal im krankenhaus und für die patienten mit.
Wenn der maßgabe wenn klare verschmutzung vorliegt oder wenn das ding durchgefeuert ist sofort zu wechseln auch wenn die zwei stunden noch nicht um sind mit eigenen abwurf behältern nur für diesen mund nasenscheide dass der gewaschen wird dass er dann zurückkommt
und das für das ganze krankenhaus gilt um die fdp drei masken und die sachen die man auf intensiv in diesem wirklich irre sohl.
Nachhaltigen oder hochkonzentrierten erosol wolken in diesem während des prozeduren entsprechend nicht woanders anzieht.
Und es gibt auch die empfehlung oder so ich weiß es von von zwei drei krankenhäusern dass sie es so machen dass nachdem sie so eine prozedur haben.
Erstmal vier stunden der raum nicht betreten wird um da möglichst das absinken zu lassen um die konzentration.
Sinken zu lassen um dann zu gucken dass du da rein zu gehen was natürlich so ein intensivpatienten der frisch intubiert ist der braucht genau am anfang.
Erstmal die aufmerksamkeit weil man hat ja
besten schlimmsten fall noch narkose medikamente gegeben zum einschlafen dann ist die kreislaufdysregulation jetzt erstmal der ganze körper muss ich jetzt erstmal auf den neuen zustand einstellen dass da jetzt nicht mehr er mit unterdruck arbeitet oder sie atmet sondern dass,
die maschine das verein macht mit überdruck dass der blutdruck einfach entsprechende andere regulation braucht weil natürlich einen überdruck in anderen rückfluss zum herzen macht als ein unterdruck und so weiter.
Und deswegen ist eigentlich so die einstellung und anpassung des beatmungsgeräte in der ersten zeit nach der intubation sehr häufig wohingegen wenn sich's eingespielt hat das auch
manchmal über den ganzen tag lang nur minimal verändert werden muss.
Das heißt die versorgung mit schutz materialien ist generell weit unter dem wünschenswerten zustand da fragt man sich es.
Ist das jetzt nur weil wir jetzt auf einmal diesen massiven ansturm haben oder weil generell die versorgung schon knapp war.
Ich kann nicht sagen wie die versorgung generell war es ist,
es ist hören sagen es ist ich weiß es von leuten direkt aus manchen kliniken dass sie sagen na ja wir haben jetzt noch material bis irgendwann nächste woche.
Und dann haben wir einfach nichts mehr das war stand letzte woche dieser aussage es gab eine kollegin die mir gesagt hat.
Als ich mal fragte hast du eigentlich schon mal geübt aus dem zeug rauszukommen nö.
Also wir haben auch auf intensiv gerade nur einen anzug den rest hat angeblich die pflegedienstleitung.
Wo nicht klar ist wie viel vorräte dann sind dann gibt es immer wieder berichte auch wo einbrüche in was weiß ich ich glaube in berlin haben sie eine eine früh geborenen station ausgeräumt wo die anzufangen haben die lager wirklich die sachen alle weg zu schließen die lager zu bewachen
weil einfach menschen einbrechen und meinen was auch immer damit machen zu müssen sei es mit profit zu verkaufen oder panik zu haben und und das machen das tut natürlich dem krankenhaus
ein extrem weh weil wenn sie nämlich noch vorräte schon lange bestellt haben dann haben die lange lieferzeiten und sie haben vielleicht noch was aber das kann dann halt dauern bis es wieder haben und das ist ein
meines erachtens nach ein ganz großes problem was wir
hier auch haben werden dass wir einfach nicht genug vorräte in den krankenhäusern haben ich im ambulanten bereich ist es wohl noch schlimmer wo die hausärzte sagen wir haben gar nichts wir kriegen auch nix es wird versprochen und wo,
ja kliniken und ärzte aufruhr oder feuerwehren aufrufe starten näht uns bitte masken.
Teilweise ist ja auch das problem gar nicht mal nur hier zu suchen es gab ja diesen fall dass die bundesregierung schon sehr wohl wusste dass ein gewisser
mehr bedarf entstehen würde dann gab es dann irgendwie eine lieferung aus afrika und dann ist irgendwie,
der komplette flugzeug inhalt irgendwie auf einmal abhanden gekommen.
Ja oder wird nicht durchgelassen.
Ich meine wir haben das in richtung schweizer auch gemacht dass halt die schweiz zwar rechtzeitig bestellt hat aber sie immer ein transit weg haben von irgendeinem durch irgendein anderes land und das war in dem fall deutschland deutschland dann erstmal gesagt hat die ist jetzt export stopp ihr kriegt das was ihr bestellt habt nicht von uns weil,
ist halt export stopp das haben sie jetzt wieder zurückgenommen aber da ist im prinzip auch das problem dass ich generell einfach einen mangel besteht das
ich habe einen bericht gelesen dass irgendwie hersteller beziehungsweise firmen die diese
schutzausrüstung vertreiben dem gesundheitsministerium schon im dezember januar eine e-mail geschickt briefe geschrieben haben leute hier passiert gerade wir bestellen chinesen in massen bei uns,
schutzausrüstung da ist vielleicht handlungsbedarf und ja.
Also da das ist ein ein sehr multikulturelles geschehen das ist ja vielleicht miss kalkulation im krankenhausbereich unterschätzung im vom vom krankenhaus unterschätzung auf behördlicher ebene und dann ist das weg organisiert worden und
ja abwarten.
Mal abwarten.
Schauen wir doch mal wie sich jetzt das gesundheitssystem in deutschland auf die aktuelle situation einstellt und was so aus deiner perspektive hier wohl der stand der dinge ist also.
Man weiß ja jetzt irgendwie da kommt was bisher macht es so den eindruck als wäre man noch nicht
an dem belastungsgrenzen angekommen.
Viele krankenhäuser stellen sich drauf ein auf verschiedene arten und weisen teilweise wenn ich es richtig sehe haben sich manche krankenhäuser darauf spezialisiert also ich glaube in berlin.
Ist es so dass wir die charité glaube ich sich irgendwie wesentlichen auf kurve konzentriert um dann andere krankenhäuser wiederum von solchen patienten auf freizuhalten weil wir haben ja auch schon besprochen es ist auch ein problem ist sozusagen
die einfälle und die anderen fälle im selben haus zu haben weil.
Ist ja auch nicht so dass sonst keiner krank ist es gibt ja auch noch alle anderen dinge wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich weniger fälle haben von
den auswirkungen von verkehrsunfällen weil einfach der verkehr zurückgeht etcetera aber leute werden krank sind schon krank müssen halt auch operiert werden etcetera und wenn das dann eben auch noch mit dieser virus behandlung dazu kommt dann ist es ein großes problem
wie was beobachtest du wie sich derzeit das system aufstellt und in welcher situation sich gerade alles befindet ende märz.
Also es ist so dass es natürlich wie auch jetzt bei den ganzen erlassen der der regierung als landesregierung ist dass es sich ein bisschen unheimlich einheitlich darstellt und das ist bei den krankenhäusern
im prinzip genauso du kannst nicht für alle krankenhäuser reden weil es in jedem krankenhaus ein bisschen anders gehandelt wird.
Manche auch arztpraxen händeln ist unterschiedlich ja ganz viele machen jetzt wenn sie das räumlich können irgendwie dass sie so eine hälfte der praxis mit
infektiösen oder potenziellen faktionen akuten sachen für patienten haben und die anderen haben halt oder baulich haben sie zwei etagen dass er eine etage dann jetzt für die chronischen patienten die halt ihr rezept verlängert haben müssen die einen blutdruck nachgeguckt
haben müssen haben und
die anderen dann halt für die akuten sachen und bei den krankenhäusern wenn's geht versuchen dieses auch also krankenhäuser mit mehreren standorten in einer stadt die versuchen das oft
oder oder macht ja auch sehr viel sinn das so zu machen dass sie sagen.
Das eine krankenhaus wird jetzt quasi für patienten oder serviert und das andere eben halt für die anderen patienten weil auch jetzt wird's jemanden mit blinddarmentzündung geben auch jetzt gibt's.
Gibt es andere erkrankungen die halt akut und auch auftreten können ja das ist einfach so magengeschwür oder sonst irgendwas.
Alles im prinzip alles ja das problem ist nur so ein bisschen dass es.
In meinen augen glaube ich schwierig sein wird diese strikte trennung aufrechtzuerhalten weil.
Das wird so flächig in meiner einschätzung sich verbreiten dass
eine strikte das ist ein krankenhaus und das ist ein normales krankenhaus ohne co wird schwierig sein wird was die italiener gesagt haben ist dass die die
unterschiedlichen bereichstrennung im krankenhaus
für patienten nicht patienten relativ zügig aufgeben mussten weil wenn's im haus ist ist es im haus und dann wird es sich in irgendeiner form verbreiten und das ist natürlich schon ein problem weil im krankenhaus liegen kranke patienten.
Und damit haben diese kranken patienten halt das durchaus das problem dass sie sich anstecken können obendrauf noch.
Und die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich anstecken oder dass es eine schwere verlauf ist ist höher als bei den zwanzigjährigen die die die zu hause sind hoffentlich.
Also diese trennung ist ist machbar die sollten wir an meinen augen auch unbedingt so viel es geht versuchen durchzuhalten die frage ist wie sehr.
Wird es in der realität funktionieren das ist genauso wie dieses mit dem beobachten mit dem man muss alles an schutzausrüstung anziehen.
Ist denn überhaupt genug da ist dann genug personal da dass man diese zwei augen prinzip machen kann.
In bezug auf wie sich die krankenhäuser vorbereiten ist es.
Sehr unterschiedlich so von meinem kleinen einblick den ich habe ist es schon alleine vom krankenhaus träger unterschiedlich gehandelt ob es jetzt noch programm ist oder nicht
die.
Einstellung des elektro programms also der geplanten hüft-op der geplanten kreuzband rekonstruktion also wenn das knie kaputt ist
wann die auf eingestellt wurden
manche haben das schon vor vor längerer zeit also früher reagiert manche haben's dann doch fast eine woche länger durch weitergemacht bei manchen läuft immer noch auch effektiv programm natürlich ein bisschen anders
was jetzt zum beispiel tumor ops angeht jemand der einen tumor hat der ist zwar jetzt nicht
sofort operieren zu operieren weil wenn man die nicht in zwei stunden sechs stunden operiert dann hat er einen noch größeres problem aber natürlich ist wenn man perspektivisch sagt dieser tumor ist jetzt so dass man ihn operieren kann er hat nicht gestreut,
wie sieht das denn aus in zwei drei monaten und wie ist die situation ist es wirklich so gut ausschiebbare das heißt dass viele noch tumoroperation weitermachen.
Manchmal ist es auch abhängig wie sie definieren was jetzt aufschieben ist und was nicht das gibt 's leider auch immer noch da gibt's keine einheitliche festlegung so dass manche krankenhäuser früh.
Effektiv programme und umfassend aktivprogramm eingestellt haben und manche das halt anders handeln.
Manche krankenhäuser schaffen es sicherlich auch dass sie sagen so jetzt ist der zeitpunkt einzuarbeiten jetzt ist der zeitpunkt zu üben
und das ist total wichtig und die zeit sollte man sich auch nehmen egal wie es aussieht dass man wirklich,
kann wenn die ersten patienten aber es ist zumindest schon mal so gemacht hat dass man das gefühl hat man kriegt das einigermaßen sicher hin wenn die ersten patienten dann tatsächlich vor einem liegen
wie kriege ich das hin mit einer schutzausrüstung zu intubieren oder
patienten von den rücken auf den bauch mit all den schläuchen zu zu drehen ohne dass da was passiert.
Um jetzt einfach das team training zu machen was viele auch berichten ist dass jetzt sozusagen die einarbeitung stattfindet für die fachfremden disziplin weil.
Anästhesisten können jetzt intubieren die haben auch alleine durch ihre facharztausbildung ein ja intensivmedizin gemacht
andere fachdisziplinen haben zum beispiel die urologen müssen es gar nicht die chirurgen und die internisten müssen ein halbes jahr nur auf intensiv verbringen während der facharztausbildung.
Das halt mann und maus im prinzip
versucht wird einzuarbeiten dass man sagt gut was können die chirurgen was können die die internisten wo wo wir teilen was auf die chirurgen schmeißen die notaufnahme die internisten machen das sind das sind die anästhesisten
gehen halt vom aktivprogramm im op betrieb zurück auf die intensivstation oder werden primär auf der intensivstation gezogen.
Das ist so das eine das andere ist so dieses beschreiben von es fühlt sich total seltsam an weil alle bereiten sich vor es gibt,
die bestrebungen dass die räume in intensivstationen umgewandelt werden also da wo monitor plätze und auch zu einem gewissen teil beatmung platze sind aber vor allem die überwachung vorhanden ist dass man den patienten auch beatmen kann.
Da intensiv plätze einzurichten dass man die operationssäle umrüsten auch wenn diese narkose beatmungsgeräte für
die normalen anästhesie betrieb eigentlich nicht dazu ausgelegt sind hat zum beispiel die firma dräger und auch die firma löwenstein und so
mit haftungs ausschuss und sonst war es hinweise oder manuelle gegeben wie man es oder was man beachten muss wenn man diese narkose geräte in einem
dauerbeobachtung betrieb umwandelt dass es.
Also geguckt wird wie man die strukturen adäquat umbauen kann und das wird jetzt gerade vollzogen es ist aber auch so dass,
viele frauen auch von mehreren fachdisziplinen weiß dass sie sagen na ja wir haben jetzt keine effektiv programm wir haben gerade gar nicht so viel zu tun.
Kannst du nochmal kurz sagen effektiv programm heißt genau was.
Effektiv heißt also es gibt wenn man jetzt operationen.
Programmiert also wenn man sagt wir machen eine operation dann gibt's halt verschiedene dringlichkeitsstufen das dringlichste ist sofort das ist was weiß ich die milz ist gerissen,
das ist ein vom von der notaufnahme nach dem autounfall direkt in den op gehen sie nicht über los sondern direkt weiter das ist sofort dann gibt es die dringlichen die müssen innerhalb von ein zwei stunden operiert werden,
beziehungsweise dann auch bis sechs stunden das hängt so ein bisschen von der indikation ab und dann gibt's halt die die verschiebbar sind also elektrik nimm election als beispiel das ist das.
Wort man kann's wählen genau man kann's wählen das heißt man sagt
heute nacht hat's gefroren wir haben jetzt hier zwanzig leute die sich die hand gebrochen haben oder das handgelenk gebrochen haben
da ist einer der hat eine grobe fehlstellung den müssen wir heute noch operieren aber die was weiß ich der der junge mann oder die alte dame da das steht eigentlich alles ganz gut da kann man gips drum machen und dann geht die erstmal nach hause oder auf station das wir hier unten weitermachen können
dass man
die quasi plant und das effektiv programm ist im prinzip das was geplant wird und was aus auswahl schmächtig stattfindet wann ist eigentlich kein blasen ok.
Ich habe immer der patient hat immer wieder mal so so geilen koliken die gallenblase soll raus das macht man nicht wenn sie akut entzündet ist wenn man's irgendwie vermeiden kann also.
Planen wir sie jetzt mal wir haben einen platz dafür in drei wochen oder sechs wochen.
Und das programm ist jetzt halt weitestgehend soweit ich das mitgekriegt habe erstmal ausgesetzt das halt nur noch
sachen gemacht werden müssen die wirklich gemacht werden müssen das ist aber auch dazu führt wenn ihr zum beispiel noch einen op-saal besetzt ist weil ein muss man mindestens freihalten damit wenn dann der patient mit dem akuten blinddarmentzündung oder so operiert werden muss auch operiert werden kann auch wenn man
kurve patienten betreut das aber.
Dann auf einmal valencia frei wir sind beim personal dass man zum glück dann auch sagt.
In überstunden frei ressourcen also dass die zeit haben dass sie sagen.
Guck mal wir haben jetzt gerade nichts zu tun im prinzip für dich geh doch jetzt mal um und mach mal deine hundertzwanzig überstunden und bummel davon mal welche abwärts je nachdem es gibt auch paar kollegen die deutlich mehr habt
je nachdem wie sie ausgezahlt werden auch weniger aber dass man gedacht komm jetzt mach du mal überstunden frei,
und geh mal ja was weiß ich auch wenn man es böse sagt geh mal ausschlafen bevor du wiederkommst.
Weil die große belastung kommt ja kommt ja wahrscheinlich noch oder ist zumindest damit zu rechnen und wenn man jetzt sozusagen noch luft hat dann soll man eben die leute auch nicht unbedingt überfordern.
Genau und gerade wenn man jetzt nichts zu tun hat also jetzt ist im prinzip üben
einarbeiten der kollegen die was weiß ich es gibt auch pflege die jetzt in der pflegedienstleitung seit zehn jahren sitzen oder zwanzig oder im controlling oder so oder leute die halt irgendwann in ihrem leben auch mal krankenschwester oder wenn ein krankheitsbild gesundheitspflege heißt es ja jetzt
fahren und die jetzt wieder eingearbeitet werden um dann wieder auf intensiv eingesetzt werden zu können.
Aber natürlich ist wenn man das so lange nicht gemacht hat muss man erstmal wieder reinkommen und die werden dann halt jetzt eingearbeitet.
Was ist denn von der einrichtung von diesem notfall- krankenhäusern die jetzt so komplett an neuen orten hochgezogen werden zu halten also man sieht das natürlich in anderen ländern schon vielfach ich glaube auch in berlin gibt es eine vorbereitung hier die messehallen entsprechend
zu zu nutzen jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon sehr ausufernd darüber geredet was so ein intensiv platz halt eigentlich alles braucht
wie wird da gearbeitet das ist ja dann sozusagen speziell auf den kohfeldt bedarf abgestellt aber da braucht man ja dann trotzdem eine ganze menge geräte man fragt sich natürlich vor allem wo kommt es her also schnell.
Ja das da hast du völlig recht ich muss ehrlicherweise sagen ich kann dir das nicht beantworten ich weiß nicht genau wie sie das betreiben wollen also es gibt natürlich auch kapazitäten noch
im sanitätsdienst der bundeswehr wo halt aber auch gerät personal pflege ärztlich und so weiter vorhanden ist die man dann auch mobil vielleicht irgendwo wenn's knallt
oder wenn halt wirklich ganz großer bedarf es dahin schicken könnte
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wie dieser betrieb von diesem großflächigen
intensiv plätzen laufen soll wie die mit was für personal die das betreiben wollen klar kann man da sauerstoffflaschen ranstellen
die wissen uns häufig ausgetauscht werden wie es da die logistik man braucht monitor man braucht beatmung platz ich weiß nicht wie das dann aussieht mit zusätzlichen geräten außer einem beatmungsgeräte spritzen pumpen also perfusoren wirst du brauchen
wie viele da irgendwie aus dem boden zauberband sind weiß ich nicht wo ich aber tatsächlich echt kritisch sehe ist.
Mir ist nicht deutlich wie sie das pflegerisch und ärztlich besetzen wollen.
Also sie sind ja gerade dabei in den also zumindest ein paar bundesländern dabei notstandsgesetze fürs gesundheitswesen,
zu machen wo halt auch zwangsverpflichtung zwangsrekrutiert von leuten mit entsprechender ausbildung vorgesehen ist.
Wo sie zu den behörden hingehen können und daten von den.
Mitarbeitern oder den den dort eingetragenen personen abrufen können dass zum beispiel die ärztekammern entsprechend die qualifikation und kontaktdaten und alles der ärzte die bei ihnen gemeldet sein müssen da sind wir alle jeder der irgendwie.
Approbation hintergrund hat es bei einer ärztekammer in irgendeiner form aufgeführt.
Was da ist das ist im moment alles im fluss das ist nicht deutlich was da noch draus wird sie sind sehr kräftig dabei die medizinstudenten.
Weiter einzusetzen von das also das praktische jahr das ist das letzte studienjahr wo man eigentlich nur noch in der klinik arbeitet
fängt jetzt schon an es werden prüfungen ausgesetzt oder auf irgendwann nachher verschoben
studenten kriegen auch wenn sie noch nicht so weit sind wir werden denen teilweise verträge in den einzelnen kliniken,
gemacht dass sie einfach auch versicherungsrecht und so gut abgesehen oder vernünftig abgesichert sind dass sie jetzt halt verträge kriegen und da dann eben auch mitarbeiten sollen gleich es wird sicherlich auch für krankenpflege schüler
und schülerinnen gelten.
Und auch für menschen aus dem rettungswesen also rettungssanitäter notfallsanitäter rettungsassistenten leute aus den hilfsorganisationen also johanniter malteser rotes kreuz.
Ich glaube aus habe ich noch vergessen.
Da wird wahrscheinlich rekrutiert aber es ist nicht für mich im moment klar kommuniziert oder oder.
Dargestellt wie sie das personell stemmen wollen.
Aber es gibt zumindest noch mobilisierung potenzial so hoffmann.
Weil das problem ist ja leider dass das gesundheitssystem jetzt vorkosten ja nicht so.
Ausgestattet war dass es personell nicht schon an vielen stellen sehr sehr eng war,
dass an vielen stellen stellen gar nicht mehr besetzt werden können ich kenne kaum eine klinik die volle stellenbesetzung hat wo dann teilweise von der geschäftsführung auch noch stellen nicht wieder ausgeschrieben werden um einfach das personal zu sparen
schichten wenn dann was weiß ich der no-go oder die erkältungswelle oder influencer durchgeht dann auf einmal
betten in intensivstationen geschlossen werden müssen weil einfach nicht genug pflegekräfte vorhanden sind das ist inzwischen so,
entgegnet worden dass der herr spahn die pflege mindest jetzt habe ich den namen vergessen ist ich glaube.
Pflege mindeststandard oder so dass also auf jeden fall die die anzahl wie viele.
Pflegekräfte mindestens vorhanden sein müssen oder wieviel sie maximal an patienten betreuen wurden wurde aufgehoben so dass die belastung da noch höher sein werden wird als sie so schon ist und dass das system vorher schon.
Nicht auf voller kapazität war.
Wie.
Wie schätzt du denn jetzt die situation ein ich meine es ist ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen das ist klar aber vielleicht versuchen wir mal so einen blick.
In die länder die jetzt ganz offensichtlich jetzt schon überrannt sind von diesem problem,
italien ist der offensichtliche fall in spanien sieht es auch nicht so gut aus es steht zu befürchten dass sich auch in den usa und im vereinigten königreich vermutlich auch nicht besonders positiv entwickelt
hat man denn sozusagen.
Auch schon irgendetwas aus italien lernen können wie man sich auf so eine überlastung noch.
Vorbereiten kann oder was man auch an hilfe für solche länder noch bereitstellen kann.
Also was ja im moment so bisschen symbolisch gemacht wird ist dass die die bundeswehr immer wieder auch patienten nach deutschland ausfliegt es sind mehrere italienische patienten die in deutschland betreut werden
ich bin nicht ganz genau informiert aber im elsas sieht's ja im moment auch sehr kritisch aus rund um straßburg
und die intensiv kapazitäten in der gegend in deutschland also die da sozusagen angrenzend sind wohl auch eher schon voll wo ich nicht weiß inwieweit die nicht einfach auch
grenzübergreifend die patienten verteilt haben was sehr viel sinn macht ähm die situation die die italiener beschreiben es gab jetzt
das habe ich mir gestern angeguckt ein tutorial wo der leiter oder der der vorsitzende der italienischen intensivmedizin gesellschaft so hinweise gegeben hat.
Der sehr.
Eindrücklich beschrieben hat was so die ganz großen probleme wo man einfach das annehmen muss und nicht verhindern kann dass die leute psychisch sehr angegriffen sind dass sie physisch extrem.
Ausgelaugt sind weil einfach das vier stunde sechs stunden in dem intensivzimmer in maske arbeiten unglaublich anstrengend ist.
Was man medizinisch beachten muss aber halt wie viel auch die logistische und die organisation drum herum in anspruch nimmt das ist ein ganz spannendes video gewesen.
Wo ich dachte ja das ist wenn's so laufen würde glaube ich gut ich befürchte dass es wenn's rund geht.
Wenig gut umsetzbar ist die situation wie sie sich in spanien und italien entwickeln und auch england und den usa ist halt.
Sehr,
multifunktionell also von verschiedenen faktoren abhängig von wir haben es nicht so schnell gemerkt wie sehr sich ausbreitet zu wir haben am anfang nicht reagiert
und entsprechend angefangen physischen abstand zwischen die leute zu bringen um einfach die zahl der neuinfektionen
zu drücken weil das ist eigentlich das einzige was wir tun können ist alles mögliche zu machen um.
Die anstieg der infektionen.
Zu verringern weil einfach ich glaube vierzehn prozent sind es die stationär behandelt werden müssen mit kurvig und
davon auch noch ein paar prozent die einfach intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden müssen und es wird einfach sich voll türmen und ich fürchte dass
einfach relativ unabhängig davon wie viele betten wählt schaffen dass es einfach trotzdem wenn's
rund geht immer noch zu wenig sein wird und dass auch die psychische und belastung von triade also dem entscheiden
welcher patient bekommt jetzt ein beatmungspflege und welcher nicht.
Also nicht nur eine entscheidung von der ist jetzt über siebzig decke ich kein beatmungspflege sondern immer die abwägung wird empfohlen über das gesamte haus wie viele patienten habe ich noch die vielleicht intensiv richtig werden wie viele habe ich sind da schon und auch mit denen die schon ein beatmungsgeräte zu haben
zu entscheiden wer bekommt denn jetzt das nächste das halte ich für extrem anspruchsvoll und auch.
Ja fordernd und psyche.
Logisch belastend.
Aus ja.
Und was halt in england und den usa ist ist dass also gerade in den usa glaube ich dass ihnen jetzt einfach ihr.
Vorher schon sehr neoliberal aufgestelltes gesundheitswesen und auch sozialversicherungsbeiträgen auf die ordentlich auf die füße fallen wird das einfach leute die keine versicherung haben.
Schwierigkeiten haben zugang zum gesundheitssystem zu kriegen dass leute.
Überhaupt keine chance haben sich irgendwie von irgendwem fernzuhalten weil sie drei jobs arbeiten müssen um überhaupt ihre miete zu zahlen die sie ja bräuchten um sich überhaupt in quarantäne zu befinden sie aber tatsächlich in not geraten um nicht rausgeschmissen zu werden
hin zu einem.
Mir fehlen die worte ihn neutral oder wohlwollend zu beschreiben ja ein ein.
Präsidenten haben das ganze nicht gut handelt
hinzu wir der markt regel schon und sie sich jetzt zwischen den staaten weil einfach niemand eingreift und dann sagt der eine staat ich zahl dir
fünf dollar für masken oder so und dann sagt der nächste ja ich gebe dir aber sechs und dass ich jetzt die tatsächlich wohl mehrfach in oder in verschiedenen ebenen mit untereinander in konkurrenz befinden für produkte.
Weil die nachfrage ist hoch angebot niedrig.
Der markt regelt.
Genau der markt regelt aber er regelt gerade nach oben sodass der ich weiß gar nicht ich glaube der gouverneur von new york jetzt neulich erzählte das irgendwie.
Geräte die sonst fünfundzwanzigtausend euro kosten halt jetzt über fünfundvierzigtausend euro kosten weil sich die staaten überbieten.
Die situation in england ist ja auch so dass sie ein sehr neoliberal aufgestelltes gesundheitswesen haben was sehr sehr knapp bemessen ist ja sie hatten ja vorher schon.
Lange wartezeiten für operationen sie haben eine kommission die entscheidet wie viel wird auf die also es sind qualis quality of life yes.
Also wie hoch ist die lebensqualität und wie viel geld ist das system bereit dafür auszugeben
haben sie halt eine sehr begrenzte kapazität nur von beatmungspflege oder allgemein intensiv plätzen ich glaube sie sind europaweit mit unter den die die geringste anzahl pro.
Einwohner hat was das ganze natürlich verschärft wir sind da in deutschland vergleichsweise gut aufgestellt wir haben in deutschland den vorteil dass.
Betont der herr trosten also der professor drosseln der da seinen täglichen podcast in ndr macht ja auch immer wieder dass wir in deutschland einfach die situation haben dass wir viel getestet haben und dadurch einfach.
Noch viel.
Wissen haben wen wir noch weiter von den anderen isolieren müssen und dass dadurch einfach auch im moment bei uns die todesstrafe noch klein ist oder ich sterberate aber auch das system wird sich erschöpfen.
Und man wartet auch jetzt teilweise auf intensivstation achtundvierzig stunden auf einen testergebnis weil's einfach kapazitäten mäßig nicht schneller geht.
Jetzt muss man sich ja bei dieser ganzen
situation auch drauf einstellen dass uns das noch sehr lange begleiten wird also derzeit ist natürlich die konzentration erheblich auf der ist-situation auf der verhinderung des unmittelbaren kollaps des nicht wahr wir gehen jetzt alle mal nicht raus und wir versuchen unsere kontakt.
Soweit einzuschränken wie es irgendwie möglich ist klar damit die infektionen zahlen jetzt erstmal sinken nicht in diesen exponentiellen bereich reingehen und dann entsprechend
natürlich weil man im
bei gut ein prozent der fälle davon ausgehen kann dass hier eine krankenhausbehandlung erforderlich ist beziehungsweise todesgefahr droht dass dann eben diese zahlen schnell eben auch unsere vielleicht noch relativ gut aufgestellt.
Zahlen und personalzahlstellen im krankenhaus betrieb dann überfordern.
Gehen wir mal davon aus dass dass wir das sozusagen in irgendeiner form schaffen werden
also das halte ich jetzt nicht für unwahrscheinlich ja wir sind halt in so einem look down das geht jetzt alles noch gut einen monat so weiter.
Und wir werden dann eben wenn's gut läuft anfang mai,
vielleicht eine eine eine öffnung eine schrittweise öffnung sehen
mit dem versuch in irgendeiner form zu einem normalzustand wieder herzukommen der virus ist ja nicht aus der welt das heißt dann werden auch nicht siebzig prozent der.
Bevölkerung irgendwie immun sein weil sie halt verhindert haben das erstmal viele leute das virus erhalten.
Wie muss ich denn unser umgang sowohl in der gesellschaft und eben dann eben auch spezifisch das
gesundheitssystem
dann darauf einstellen wie wie können wir denn überhaupt das dann in der zukunft moderieren damit wir diese balance zwischen öffentlichen leben wirtschaftsleben sozialen leben und sicher leben in irgendeiner form noch in balance bekommen.
Schwierige frage also es gibt da ja mehrere szenarien des ich persönlich glaube nicht dass wir es komplett unterhalb der kapazitätsgrenze schaffen werden.
Oder fürchte ich ich hoffe natürlich dass das klappt aber
wenn man dann die rechnung ansieht wenn das dadrunter bleibt wie lange es dann dauert um diese siebzig prozent durch solche unsre zum erreichen der herden immunität zu erreichen wie lange das dauert
dann ist das ein szenario was uns mehrere jahre begleiten wird das wird immer wieder auch probleme dann machen.
Ich gehe davon aus dass.
Um das wirklich hinzukriegen einen blog down sehr viel länger als vier wochen wahrscheinlich nötig werde aber wäre ich bin weder epidemiologische noch bin ich da irgendwie jemand der da gut rechnen kann ich kann einfach ja
ich sehe die situation im krankenhaus und lese halt viel.
Es wird wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen dass wir wieder aufmachen und dann wird wieder eine welle kommen und dann würden wir die inflationsrate wieder steigen und dann werden wir wieder zumachen müssen und dann wird's wieder steigen und wenn's wieder aufgemacht wird also dass das so in wellen läuft.
Um irgendwie auch noch ein normales wirtschaftliches wirtschaftliche perspektive zu haben
oder aber es ist wirklich sehr sehr langsam und es bleibt dadrunter dann ist das aber etwas was uns auch wahrscheinlich noch bis über das jahresende hinaus begleiten wird aber.
Was wie sich das genau ausspielt wie sich das genau verhalten wird also das was entschieden also diejenigen die entscheiden wie es weitergehen soll das ist die politik.
Ob es noch ein look down gibt oder nicht wie lange der dauert oder nicht.
Was ich tatsächlich fürchte ist was im moment noch so überhaupt nicht im fokus ist wie es danach weitergeht wenn diese akutphase überstanden ist wie viele werden denn dann noch im gesundheitssystem.
Sinnvoll arbeiten können weil sie es also das braucht ja für alle erstmal zeit um dann diese hochgradig psycho.
Physische belastung die so ein.
Über der kapazitätsgrenze arbeiten mit schweren entscheidungen bedeuten würde das muss man ja auch erstmal verarbeiten.
Da ist die frage wo ich überhaupt nicht weiß aber ich ich befürchte dass da auch eine hohe rate an ja.
Burn-out und allgemein folgen danach kommt.
Ich habe das jetzt im wesentlichen gefragt um vielleicht daraus so ein bisschen mal abzuleiten okay was was können wir alle jetzt sozusagen tun ich denke was ich.
Im kleinen verändert was vielleicht noch nicht der große move ist wir haben jetzt alle viel über hygiene gelernt ja das problem an sich ist auch.
Zumindest in weiten teilen denke ich verstanden worden selbst wenn jetzt alles wieder normal betrieben werden darf in anführungsstrichen wird eine zurückhaltung.
Erstmal da sein ja leute werden sich.
Also manche manche wahrscheinlich schon aber nicht nicht alle werden sich wieder sofort aufeinander stürzen wir werden dann wahrscheinlich auch die psychologischen auswirkungen.
Von dieser situation dass man jeden erstmal so potenziell auch als bedrohung ansieht erleben.
Auch wenn eine gewisse normalisierung hier und da natürlich auch stattfinden wird denkst du dass das unterschied machen kann wenn sich eben bestimmte verhaltensweisen.
Manifestieren und man eben vielleicht auch versucht die sozusagen auch öffentlich zu begleiten indem man sagt so leute okay alles klar
sieht zwar jetzt erstmal so aus als ob wir die erste welle überlebt haben aber wir brauchen jetzt einfach zumindest für die nächsten paar jahre andere grundregeln meine wahrscheinlich
wird er allein durch diese ganze hände waschen frei auch die zahl von grippeinfektion etcetera zurückgegangen sein vermute ich mal.
Das ist ja sozusagen dann auch mal ein ganz interessanter aspekt und das könnte sich ja dann auch langfristig ein bisschen manifestieren.
Also was ich tatsächlich glaube ich noch mehr einschleifen muss jetzt ist wirklich dieses abstand halten das klappt in vielen fällen gut aber ich war gestern beim wieder einkaufen und habe mich so ja.
Durch die stadt bewegt und dachte dafür dass sie jetzt eigentlich alle abstand halten ist ja aber verdammt viel betrieb und das an der bushaltestelle die fünfzehn leute die da warten naja also das ist tatsächlich total wichtig ich.
Ich sehe auch dass das gemeinsame mund nase schutz tragen um.
Wir schützen euch vor falls ich schon eine infektion habe weil ja im schnitt wohl zirka zwei tage vor auftreten der ersten symptome die leute schon infektiös sind.
Das heißt man merkt selber noch gar nicht ist aber schon infektiös dass das halt durch ein selbst genähten mund nase schutz.
Deutlich reduziert wird auch wenn das eigene risiko sich zu infizieren nicht so unglaublich viel sinkt aber auch da ist es natürlich eine reduktion und direkter schutz für die für die rachen schleimhaut.
Was ist perspektivisch bedeutet finde ich extrem schwierig abzuschätzen.
Ich glaube schon oder ich habe die hoffnung dass einfach vieles an.
Neu gedachten routinen jetzt zwangsweise ja also die die schnellste weg zur digitalisierung erleben wir gerade jetzt was auf einmal für arbeitsplätze doch vielleicht in homeoffice funktionieren.
Welche wege vielleicht doch nicht notwendig sind dass man nicht das dient den dienstwagen in amiland mit einem flugzeug jedes mal hier angucken und bestellen muss weil hier sitzt die in der zentrale irgendwie die dienstwagen beschaffung und.
Man muss dann vielleicht doch nicht jedes mal fliegen dass wir vielleicht auch merken wie manche dinge wichtiger sind als andere.
So an gesellschaftlichen werten wäre wünschenswert.
Ich freue mich ein bisschen auch wenn's zisch ist das jetzt scheinbar die klimaziele zwanzig zwanzig für deutschland ein haltbar werden.
Was das ganze bei rauskommt keine ahnung.
Das wissen wir alle nicht aber auf jeden fall denke ich ist es jetzt genau der richtige zeitpunkt mal drüber nachzudenken was.
Was hast du mit uns machen könnte und ich fühle mich gerade so was so den umgang miteinander betrifft also gesellschaftlicher wandel ist möglich in dem moment wo man es vorgelebt bekommen ich erinnere mich gerade an so einem detail.
Ein bisschen relaxed aber könnte vielleicht ja auch helfen in kolumbien.
Wurde versucht das verhalten der leute im straßenverkehr so ein bisschen.
Zu moderieren das rote ampeln respektiert werden und irgendwie aber auch wenn die leute über die straße gehen et cetera und da hat sich die regierung was nettes einfallen lassen und hat einfach.
Größere teilmenge an künstlern.
Engagiert die dann als pantomime durch die stadt gegangen sind und den leuten sozusagen pantomimisch
das richtige verhalten vorgelebt haben und das hatte in der tat positive wirkung so das wäre dann vielleicht auch mal was für unsere bushaltestellen und so wenn man solche truppen aufbieten würden die dann einfach in der öffentlichkeit das sozusagen auf diese art und weise zelebrieren das nur mal so als.
Mit mit ich baue mir ein einen ständer mit einem hula-hoop-reifen um bauch und damit ihr auch alle abstand zu mir einhaltet oder so.
Genau frida vielen vielen dank für diesen wertvollen einblick danke dir.
Ja und vielen dank fürs zuhören hier das war's und ich werde mal schauen was für andere aspekte ich hier noch beleuchten kann.